all right so welcome everybody just
before we get started just like to
introduce myself my name is Sam Jenkins
I'm a grandmaster from California have
played several times in the US Olympic
team including our last gold medal at
the Baku Olympiad I also got an
individual gold medal in Norway and so
I've been coming to the st. Louis chess
club for many many years I played my
first US Championship here in 2009 now
we're here nine years later and I'm back
in at this point I've actually just come
out with my first book called small
steps to giant improvements Master pawn
play and chess and I'm the book is not
yet been released the general public but
I'm giving a pre-release
lecture here where you can buy the book
and I will sign it for you and you get
it early then you have to pay shipping
so I'd like to talk a little bit about
what it's the book is covering it's all
about pawn play and the key premise is
that pawns do not move backwards now
this is something that everybody knows
but it's something that is very
important to remind us of now pawns
represent half of the chessmen you're
awarded at the beginning of the game you
must play with them well or else things
will not go your way so in order to
demonstrate a little bit about what I
mean
I'd like to start by talking about this
position here does anybody recognize it
it's a little it's an infamous position
alright so this is a game from its kiss
para pagar from 1994 and so black here
kiss para have picked up his night on d7
and placed it on c5 and then there's
some controversy as to what happened
next I think that what officially
happened according to the actual video
is he released the night for such a
small fraction of a second that even he
wouldn't know of course this move simply
walked straight into Bishop c6 because
the real Constituent no longer defends
the square and the rock on e8 will be
lost the ruling was that kiss bara if it
obviously touched his knight but the
tournament director didn't have instant
replay at the time he rolled that he had
not actually released the night that he
still had his fingers on it when it was
on the c5 square he would have to move
the knight but Knight c5 would not
for smooth had night c5 been played
Bishop c6 happens and this Bishop is
hitting both the Queen and the rook and
Kasparov who was just up a healthy pawn
is now losing material later in his
annotations Kasparov gave Quincy for
suggesting that this is a draw it is not
after Bishop takes e8y just winning
Kasparov said that after an IED c4 that
white has enough that black here has
enough counter play because the Queen on
d6 is hit Knight f2 is coming and white
cannot actually take this night with
anything because if he takes with the
knight on e4 they all come Queens you to
mate protect with rook on e4 they'll
come queen d1 mate none of this will
work but White has a nice winning shot
first Bishop takes f7 check King takes
f7 and now this very strong move Queen
takes b6 guarding the after you square
so that night tonight so f2 doesn't come
black can try taking this Knight now a
maximalist will actually realize that y
can just force mate with the move rook
to a1 here but if you don't actually see
that there's nothing wrong with Queen d6
check simply grabbing the nut on d2
white ends up material to the good and
is just winning Queen h4 instead would
have been a draw because after a bishop
takes c8 and Knight g4 that's right on
h3 is quite hard to deal with are the
threat on g2 is hard to deal with
because if h3 black can go and I def to
check and then they takes h3 or Knight
g4 check and he will have a perpetual at
his disposal now you might say well what
is the relevance of all this we're
getting to that shortly the ruling was
far I've had to move his night so he
realizes that Knight c5 is a bad idea he
goes Knight to f8 now a lot of has been
discussed about this game in terms of
what was the ruling on the touch move
was it appropriate was the result right
such did something have been changed did
the arbiter scroop did the players screw
up Ditka Sparra of lie through his teeth
or was he just mistaken none of that
really matters to me at all what I found
interesting was the key point we see
next Pulgar plays Knight to e4 now what
should black play here this is a very
important move in a very important
concept to understand
any thoughts I think I'm gonna go for
the best move is to you know put your
tail between your legs admit you made a
mistake and play knight back to d7 you
don't have to be a world champion to
realize that Knight to f8 was a mistake
you know but to err is human we all know
that but when you place a piece on a bad
square and in some way hinder your
position there is no rule at all saying
that you cannot just take that move
right back and put the piece right back
where it came from once you've realized
this move was incorrect with pawns you
do not get this luxury at this point
black is still better and he went on to
win a nice game let's move on to see
what happens when you make a similar
kind of mistake with a pawn moving
forward many years this is actually one
of my games from 2012 I was defending
this Queen endgame I had the white
pieces against a very strong German
Grandmaster Georg Meier now looking back
it really pains me the way I played this
position so the whole premise is pawns
not moved backwards there I believe
there are five specific reasons that you
may wish your pawn can move backwards
but you find that it cannot they are in
order first the pawn is simply
vulnerable it has gone too far into the
enemy's position it can no longer be
defended it will be surrounded and
captured or at least arrest second it
can it is released control of a key
square that you would like to be
controlling this will be frequently seen
when your opponent has a nice outpost
that they're using and you cannot kick
their piece off of it because your pawn
has been pushed too far
it can also be blocking your own pieces
a very frequent example what I've seen
in this book is for anyone who plays the
Sicilian dragon or any or the Gruen felt
or anything like this you know that the
g7 Bishop is the pride of your position
if you ever play the move f6
your blunting your bishop and you will
always basically always want to be
wanting to play this move f6 back to f7
to open that Bishop up
that's why f6 is a strategic mistake in
such positions fourth and fifth reasons
fourth is it can compromise your King
safety this is very basic you want
especially in the middle game to have
pawns around your King so that he is
safe from any kind of attack now and
then the last reason is that it can make
a hook in the position let's see what
happens here when I made a bad pawn move
that I could not take back the way
Kasparov could
sort of take back Islam of yes it came
at the cost of two Tempe so at this
point I'm defending a queen end game one
pawn down but blacks pawn structure is
fractured there are very few pawns left
on the board my king is well placed I
don't have any immediate weaknesses this
definitely should be a draw and it
should not be a super difficult draw
either all I had to do was essentially
do nothing any old move will draw let's
say Queen D for looks most natural to me
just a I guess sort of I the f6 pawn it
doesn't really matter but I was scared
of some kind of plan with black playing
King g6 to f5 and eventually getting his
King into the game perhaps in
conjunction with a move like Queen h1
check and then his King can come even
further into g4 and if something like
that happened I thought actually black
will have winning chances and I could
end up losing so my goal to prevent that
was to play the move f5 so this move is
multi-purpose it is cutting black off
from access to the g6 square so the
black King cannot enter the position by
the rote we just described but it does
allow him to play King aged six to g5
and I had calculated a variation my
point was next move no matter what black
plays I'm going to put my Queen on f4
and at this point there is just no way
the black King will ever enter my
position and I calculated one key
variation of if black plays Queen edge
one check King f1 and now Queen c1 which
seems like a strong move to prevent me
from playing Queen f4 because that would
trade down into a pond on game then
black is ready to come with King h6 next
this is another thing that I think is
very important to know for all chess
players it's not really the subject of
the book but it's always something I
think we should be saying is if you have
a key positional idea in this case white
playing Queen f4 to shut out the black
King and your opponent prevents you from
doing so in this case by black playing
Queen c1 the first question should
always ask yourself is what happens if I
just do it anyway here we find out Queen
f4 is just to draw it's not especially
difficult to calculate after it takes
takes let's say if black tries to bring
his king to support the pawn we noticed
that after a king g3 black cannot play
King to i-5 because the board and i-5
does not exist the the board ends at the
H file and at this point there's no way
for the black King to support his pawn
further much more challenging as if
black brings the King back trying to
bring it all the way around to bring the
King around to d6 and e4 and take my
pawns
while I'm distracted by the H pawn but
this is various
it forward calculation move remove one
at a time there's no variations to
calculate there's no side anything you
just get all the way up here
you realize this is just a draw all the
pawns are traded King takes f4 King
takes f6 and then whatever he does that
this is a draw similarly you can take on
f5 first but after taking on f7 you will
not be able to take my f4 pawn without
losing f6 I calculated this all
reasonably well but of course my
opponent came up with a move he
immediately rattled off a move that I
hadn't even consider which was very
powerful Queen to g1 now what has
happened is he wants to play the exact
same variation except after Queen f4 he
will play queen f1 check and queen takes
f4 here we have the exact same position
except my king is on III not f2 as a
result I am one tempo down on this key
variation after a King f8 king f2 King
e7 King g3 King desex King itch for we
take all this I go after the pawns and I
lose by one move actually here King g7
might be a drop but take this pawn is
just winning it's just over so you could
say that he's out calculated me although
I think Queen G one's a reasonably
simple move any case at this point it
happens that my whole ploy with Queen f4
has failed and then I realized well I've
just put my pawn on f5 I have made a
giant weakness in my position that's
very easy for him to attack with both
his Queen and his king when previously I
had no weaknesses well let me pull up
his bharathan bring my pawn back to f4
and admit my mistake that's not gonna
happen this is why pawn player is
extremely punishing and that's why I've
decided to write a book on it you really
want to make sure that you're pushing
your pawns correctly whenever you push
your pawn you're making a weakness
whenever you push your pawn you're
closing a line you're also opening lines
and potentially probing for your
opponent's weaknesses now you might be
scared of pushing pawns but trust me you
will never make it very far as a chess
player by only playing Knight f3 Knight
c3 rook b1 rook g1 you clearly have to
push pawns at some point in the game to
make any kind of progress striking this
balance is tough and this is what the
book is about
now here's it happens Queen f4 actually
is a draw but it's quite tough to
calculate and at this point we're
looking at only moves and I was putting
myself in a position where I have to
calculate
very complicated variations only moves
one reason realistically I could have
just sort of just started making moves
and hitting the clock if I had not
played f5 and nothing really to worry
about after a queen f1 check it turns
out that this variation is still a draw
like a king f2 is fine but White has to
take a completely different route and
instead of going after black spawns
simply try to box blacks King out by
maintaining the opposition now he's able
to do so after a move like king g5 the
only move is king h5 keeping the distant
opposition this is sort of endgame stuff
and largely outside the scope of what
I'm hoping to discuss but it's sort of
the main point here is that making this
big pawn weakness forced me to be
finding only moves and calculating
accurate variations in a position that
really should have been an easy draw
that I could train my golden retriever
to do if I needed to instead I put
myself in a spot where I had to find
some good moves right when you do that
it's very hard psychologically to
recover I was a young player at the time
and I did not do so I sort of had of
inertia played Queen d2 just trying to
sort of box out blacks Queen and then of
course eyeing the h6 course that he
can't get through and already after
Queen f1 check my f5 pawn is simply
dropping there was nothing I could do
about it
Queen f2 leads to a lost pawn on game
because blacks King gets to g5 before I
can come to f4 so I tried King e4 but
after a quince tea forecheck
I'm losing the pawn by force once again
Queen g4 leads to a lost pawn ending if
King f3 he has queen g4 check and if
King III is I played he has Quincy 5
check and if I try to stay in touch with
the pawn with King f4 king e4 Queen e5
check will calm ultimately my f5 pawn is
lost and it was lost just a few moves
after I so foolishly pushed it to f5 now
as soon as this position came after a
Queen g1 and I realised I couldn't play
Queen f4 I immediately regretted my
position my decision to play f5 and of
course f5 was a mistake but the problem
is like we're saying pawns do not move
backwards and these create long-lasting
permanent problems so when we broke down
the reasons the 5 were that I've
described the pawn is weak the you're no
longer controlling a key square
you're blocking lines for your pieces
you have loosened your Kings cover or
you have made a hook in the position it
should be pretty obvious which of those
five reasons is the one that this move
f5 was the wrong move which one is that
sorry yeah it's too far advanced but
there are five reasons that the pawn
could be too far advanced that I've just
described which of those five reasons
yes I that's the whole thing but it can
be too far to your plants camp for any
number of reasons and the question is
why is it too far the exactly the pond
and the pond is vulnerable it's not like
I've lost control of the key square or
I've blocked my pieces it's just simply
this pawn is hard to defend now when it
was easy to defend before but there are
all sorts of other reasons and I'd like
to move on to a game played quite
recently where a very strong player fell
victim to a similar kind of thing so
anybody recognize this position and then
just a few days ago yes yes Aronian was
playing white against Kramnik here and
so he played a very innocent looking
pawn move that I believe completely lost
him the game yeah I mean I don't think
he necessarily has to resign after
playing this move but his position
becomes very very difficult and it is
because he pushed upon that he later
wished he could move backwards so
huronian pled to move h3 now it's hard
to imagine this being a losing move
because I mean come on it's just making
look for the King it's controlling the
g4 square it's doing all these useful
things but one of these five reasons for
one of these five reasons the pawn is
too far forward yes sir
exactly reason number five this move has
created a hook who knows what a hook is
a hook is a pawn that can be attacked
and that cannot move again so as such
lines will open if another pawn attacks
it this is mostly relevant in closed
positions where you're better on one
side of the board and worse on the other
you want to avoid making hooks on the
side in which you are worse but in in
open positions that can matter too by
playing h3 White has opened himself up
to a very simple plan from black to play
g5 g for this will force open White's
Kings side it will compromise as pawns
the
he will have fewer defenders there will
be open lines and indeed Kramnik simply
pled the move rook g8 now this seems
like almost a beginner move a mysterious
rook move but his point is very simple
he was going to play g5 g4 and he's
going to give mate and there's basically
nothing white can do about it
well what we'd love to do is say you
know what I'd like to just play h3 to h2
here thank you very much so now that you
cannot open these lines to my King and
furthermore you've played this silly
rook g8 and you cannot castle and
there's no reason for you to play rook
g8 if g5 g 4 doesn't meet me
unfortunately after h3 we've seen that
pawns to not move backwards so Aronian
played king h1 I think his point was
that if he makes a normal developing
move say Knight c3 that black is able to
play g5 because if white takes the pawn
black has Bishop takes h3 and after G
takes h3 I guess h6 is probably the
easiest and the point is black is not a
piece for the moment but this Bishop on
g5 is pinned it will be captured and
then what black will would be ready to
play g5 g for again or potentially
switch over to the H file with a very
strong attack incoming so Aronian tried
king h1 but this was a futile attempts
g5 it's not like white can stop it
so in the correspondence games in the
computer black was always playing h6
this may well be the best move but what
Kramnik play doesn't offend me in any
way he played node h5 so his plan is to
play a g5 G for this should be
reasonably straightforward and he's
asked he's pointing out that the Queen
now controls the g5 score as well if you
were to play g5 here we see our own
Ian's point with King each one is after
Bishop takes g5
there's no way to to punish white for
this because after Bishop takes H 3 GH
age 6 no longer wins the piece since the
King is not on g1 anymore and y can
simply save as bishop and remain a piece
of the good so but by playing Knight h5
wide black is ready for g5 next white
tried c3 but this is a bit slow
after g5 white played Knight takes e5
exploiting the tactical energy and the
position pointing out that first of all
if the Queen were to recapture here Y
can take the net on h5 he can play d4 to
win the piece back like say takes after
d4 black has a lot of hanging pieces and
will lose a bunch of material and
opening the center is a good way to
punish black for trying to play on the
Kings side
but unfortunately kramnik just went
straight through with g4 and there's
really nothing to be done about black
opening the Kings side and I don't
really want to show the rest of this
game just because I think a whole bunch
of other people are gonna be showing it
in the next few days if they haven't
already I also think it's somewhat
outside the scope of what I'm hoping to
discuss the real point was that this
move h3 turned out to be White's undoing
and it turned out to be so very very
early in the game and I've listed
several guidelines in my book as to how
to avoid making poor pawn moves like
this so the way the book works is I've
taken all five of these reasons that
upon may want to move backwards and I
have dedicated a chapter to each of them
on avoiding having this kind of scenario
come up with Neron games and obviously
you know we're only talking about hooks
in this one I guess you could argue this
sort of fits in with loosening the Kings
cover but then again just as much as
avoiding losing hidden chests because
let's say in this case you've made poor
pawn moves there's also winning chess
games now people make poor pawn moves
all the time as Aronian I've clearly
demonstrated look the guy is on +1 in
the candidates tournament right now is
obviously an absurdly strong player he's
been well over 2800 before it's not like
you know he's some idiot who made a bad
pun if he's a very very strong player
who made a bad pawn move and that's what
you should be trying to exploit when it
happens however you'll find that more
often than not people don't just make
stupid pawn moves on their own they
often need some encouragement and often
even more directly force so I'd like to
talk about a game that I played now this
was and this is on the same concept of
hooks and King safety so this is a
position I got against Swedish
Grandmaster Yanni Hector at the
politican Cup in 2016 at this point I
was still in my preparation and I
believed that white is slightly better
because he hits a big center the problem
is like any Slav player will know you
have a very solid position it's hard to
actually suggest an active plan for
white to improve his game what I
prepared was the move a six or so excuse
me a six was played I prepared for c5
which is blacks attempt to immediately
break down my center and if I recall my
preparation was
- plane I'd be five because if he
retreats the bishop I think d5 is very
strong and the main line of my
preparation was Knight takes e4 Knight
takes D 696 d c5 Knight c4 and Knight c4
at the end of all this black is unable
to take the pawn on c5 on account of
Bishop d6 when I take in exchange and at
the end of all this I'm going to put the
net on d6 it's not that impressive
because black can play Knight d5 back
and she's got a decent Bishop and
opposite bishops on the board but I
thought white was somewhat better here
when he's gonna get this outpost at
night on d6 blocking the D file and
potentially attack the b7 pawn in any
case that's where I come up with before
the game but the guy played a6 which
struck me as a slow move it's clear it's
not a stupid move it's not like he's you
know made a whole ton of weaknesses it's
not like this a pawn suddenly wants to
move back to a7 I'd even argue it's a
useful move if black wants to play c5
and my goal is to play Knight b5 next he
stopped me from achieving that in
addition he can also potentially prepare
the move b7 to b5 to harass my pieces so
at this point I was out of my
preparation and I had some idea of how
these positions sort of worked but I was
quite happy with him when I came up with
here so white is slightly better for
sure he has more space he's got active
pieces some lead in development but he's
there's really not much for him to
actually do a leading development is a
temporary advantage that will go away
over time as your opponent develops
their pieces and the space advantage if
your opponent is good squares for all
their pieces it's not that important and
more importantly here black is ready to
break down my space advantage next move
with c5 so why does a very strong move
here I'd like to see if anybody can
suggest it
okay so that's a tactical resource the
point now is that 'if I've is going to
come next right
this is decent but I did not think it
was amazing for example if black plays
rook takes f7 and say e5 or did you want
to take on d6 first and only then play
e5 okay so II five and let's say Bishop
b8 he takes f6 rook takes f6 at this
point I think White's still slightly
better but I don't love the way the game
has developed in the last few moves just
because I think the space advantage is
gone pieces have been exchanged I think
that kind of thing is sort of in Black's
favor white has a little bit of pressure
on the e6 pawn but it should be easily
alleviated black is ready to play Bishop
takes g3 and x bring his rook to e8 or
f8 he can or even d8 to attack the d4
pawn he can play ninety five if needed
probably whites a little better but I
think he has a stronger option so I
remember and well you should always be
looking out for tactics at any moment
every moment in your game really and you
should be calculating key variations to
try to achieve what you want to achieve
that is a little bit outside the scope
of this book so this is more about
strategic play with pawns so anybody
else like to suggest a move okay f4 was
my first instinct and it's not a bad
idea at all it is part of White's plan
but I do think it's inaccurate here the
problem is after b5 black is getting a
fair amount of counter play specifically
because of one key point which is that
after c5 my whole goal was to always
play D take c5 and this has actually
helped a lot when black plays b5 because
it's not going to go here it seems much
harder for black to get the c5 advance
and now that the pawn on d5 is hanging
right but here you can play c5 and the
big problem is that after DC if Bishop
takes c5 check King h1 white is just
better he can probably he will probably
just win this pawn on d5 without too
much discussion it's not the end of the
story because the pawn on e4 is a little
bit loose but the real problem is that
by playing f4 now this Bishop on g3 is
blocked which means that black can take
on e5 we're forcing you to seriously
compromise your structure
after 97 black will take back the pawn
on c5 the pawn on e5 is now a weakness
and it seems like Black has somewhat
turn things around I don't necessarily
think he's better yet but I think white
is miss played this a bit so then I go
forward with the move I played which was
very strong
I played the move Bishop h4 so this pins
the knight to the Queen let's say black
were to play c5 continuing along with
his plan to break down my center
what will white play now after Knight to
g4 yeah around here black should
consider resigning
he is absolutely dead bee five is coming
and there is nothing to be done if black
words have played g5 now to try to break
the pen I have Knight takes h6 check in
Bishop takes g5 after a night g4 black
is just done for there is nothing else
to do we can stop the clocks so Knight
g4 is a massive threat yes ok black has
some time to deal with it it's not like
I've played Knight g4 yet it's just it's
a threat it's as if you know someone
attacks your Queen you deal with the
threat like any others ok how does black
deal with the threat if Knight g4 if
Queen d8 I think the other gentleman is
a tactical idea of Knight takes f7 will
be pretty devastating because now the e6
pawn hangs at the end and when that
comes there's gonna be a pin on the rook
Queen d8 is also very sad move in
general if you have to do it you have to
do it you should not like discard and
ugly move just because it is ugly
sometimes this is required yeah that's
what he played now Yanni Hector's strong
Swedish Grandmaster do you think he
didn't know that g5 weakens his king he
was fully aware of all of that for sure
the real point I did not leave him any
choice in the matter
after a bishop h4 black must play g5
because he's going to get demolished
next move I mean maybe he can try Queen
c7 but I believe after shattering the
kingside pawn structure with an idea for
coming and E 5 is next I'd be shocked if
black can survive this I think he will
just get made it
so really black had no choice but to
play g5 now I play Bishop back to g3
okay I'm my last on my last two moves I
have played Bishop Mitch for Bishop to
e3 why doesn't black just play G v g7
and offer me a draw so I'd you want to
repeat the moves this is the whole
promise pawns do not exactly pawns do
not move backwards and it can be very
much worthwhile to provoke an enemy pawn
forward if it hinders their position in
some way now we've already discussed the
five reasons that upon may wanna move
backward pawn is vulnerable it is no
longer controlling key squares it is
blocking your pieces it has become a
hook or it compromises your King safety
now two of these four or five reasons
are relevant here which two are they
that is true what is the other truth to
it yes it is a hook this phone on g5 you
is not going to go suggest that the move
f4 which seems pretty simple gain space
in the center and everything now when
you play off four you're gonna blow up
blacks King and wake up and sleep
sleeping rook on f1 right when f4 comes
black will be unable to prevent white
from opening the F file towards his king
and activating this last piece that the
one piece of his that hasn't served an
active role yet this game this pawn on
g5 sticks out like a sore thumb it would
love to go back to g7 this is what
you'll find though is oftentimes when
you play strong opponents for the most
part they're not gonna make stupid pawn
advances on their own accord okay we
found this exception with Aronian people
do do it but it's much better if you can
provoke them into doing it now this one
I think provoked is perhaps the wrong
word because it wasn't like oh I didn't
meant to no I forced him he really did
not have a choice but you'll often find
that even just making simple moves like
I've already talked about the Grune felt
or the dragon as examples where the
bishop on g7 is sort of the Pride and
power of blacks position and a lot of
these positions white puts the bishop on
g5 just to annoy the e7 pawn and provoke
you into playing f6 at any moment you
can play f6 and send this bishop packing
but you've blocked your own bishop in so
this is all about provocation now the
way the game continued black should have
played c5 here he needed to make counter
play in the center right away
and after your takes takes I should play
king h1 f4 is coming next and white is a
dangerous initiative it's important to
point out black can try to his best
thing to do here is to try to exchange a
bunch of pieces
the fewer pieces are on the board the
less likely I am to made him the problem
is the what he really wants to do is
play knight c6 and at this point I can
probably just give up on my attack and
go upon grabbing on a6 it's not a great
pawn but it's a pawn I also could throw
it for if I wanted to I gave some
variation here Brooke d8 and I wanted to
take on da cuz I didn't want to let
black play Rick do you want and rook see
it's the rook da trick d8 and f4
okay I think blacks position is quite
dangerous the game goes on black is not
lost but I think I would much prefer
white instead my opponent played b5 and
I view this to be a strategically losing
decision because after ABA B and Bishop
b3 now I'll be very hard for black to
get NC 5 just because as b5 point is
hanging and if you cannot play c5 to
open the position then f4 is this going
to come and it's going to be demolition
game continued 97 takes takes a 4 at
this point it's just so obvious if black
could play g5 to g7 he'd probably be
basically fine here I mean but he can't
now at the time of the game I was
expecting him to just trade everything
enough for to try to alleviate some of
the pressure and turtle up with Bishop
g6 and King g7 and sort of say yes my
king side has been somewhat compromised
but it's not over now the best move was
I believe rook f6 King g7 e 5 and I
think h4 h5 is coming very quickly and
if black ever plays Knight d5 I can take
it and play Bishop c2 this is what the
computer gave but important what I came
up with is not as good but it's still
pretty strong I wanted to play rook h4
I'm going to talk this pawn and there's
always a key part of chess is whenever
you have an advantage of some kind in
this case I have a dynamic advantage
that blacks King is simply unsafe you
should always be looking for
opportunities to exchange one advantage
for another if it becomes necessary and
what I had seen is after King do too I
can
kingi it I can play Queen d2 attacking
this pawn now my queen is probably a
worse place to hear after h5 and i can
just forget my attack
clip the spawn on b5 pointing out the
nighttime before is hanging now after
something like this pretty unlikely
blacks gonna get mated the bishop on g6
is a good defender and all that and my
rook on h4 is a little misplaced but
I'll have a very healthy pawn and
there's not anything great for black to
do I'm solid and I'm a clean pawn up so
this was my intention I think the
computers way is stronger but instead my
opponents tried to keep more pieces on
the board with Bishop e7 but then we
sort of see that now he's really missing
this pawn on g7 both because I was able
to open the F file for my rook and
because his King now has no cover
I played Bishop e5 and it turns out
weirdly enough black is just completely
incapable of stopping this basic threat
of Bishop f6 followed by like Queen h5
taking on g5
he tried f6 himself but this allows
white to bring more pieces into the
attack does anybody see a good candidate
move
your Bishop is attacked do you want to
move them away or should we threaten
something bigger yeah
Quinn g4 is absolutely crushing this
pawn on e6 is under attack black does
not have time to take my bishop because
of bishop takes c6 check when his Queen
will be lost if you put the only way to
defend this pawn is king f7 which fails
for I don't know how many reasons but I
think the easiest is probably Bishop
takes f6 followed by e5 but Queen takes
g5 is more than enough
I mean basically any sensible move will
win for white instead my opponent tried
Knight d5 which was sort of this is the
move of a desperate man but still White
has to be reasonably precise like for
example I saw some funny trickery my
first instinct was to play Knight takes
d5 see d5 Bishop d5 but now
unfortunately you can play f5 breaking
the pin on the e6 pawn and next up
you'll take on g5 and this one I had to
calculate reasonably precisely but it's
still pretty straightforward I just
traded one adventure for another I
played II d5 after Fe I'm probably not
gonna made any more because I lost my
bishop which was the key attacking piece
but after d c6 black is gonna lose a ton
of material if he takes my pawn back I
will go Bishop takes c6 check and Bishop
d5 I'm taking the rook in the corner I'm
gonna be like up an exchange in two
pawns and blacks Kings still pretty open
so instead he tried rook takes f1 rook
takes f1 queen takes d4 and black can
rejoice because the Queen's came off but
unfortunately for him my c6 pawn
immediately decides the game it just
becomes a queen so that was sort of
another one of those cases of exchanging
one advantage for another so obviously
there's a lot more to it than just this
and that's why I hope you will buy this
lovely book and learn more about it but
I go into great detail on all these
topics and I'm offering a lot of
guidelines as to how to avoid making
these kinds of poor decisions with your
own pawns as well as how to provoke your
opponent's punch forward now well the
major premise of the book is pawns do
not move backwards there is a secondary
part at the end which is that pawns
seldom move sideways they move sideways
when they capture and a lot of the times
you'll see positions where let's say
your queen has just been taken and
you're thinking or someone's thinking
and it's because he's got like four
different ways to take back the Queen
and all of them lead to and like you
know two of them will lead to different
pawn structures just either pawn can
take or you can take with one of the
pieces to leave the pawn structure as is
so in general it's much harder to just
expect your opponent to make unforced
errors when talking about pawns moving
sideways because the only way that pawn
moves sideways is when they're taking
one of your pieces so unless you are
habitually just placing pieces on
squares where your opponent's pawns can
take them which I hope you're not doing
this is much more forceful in its nature
it's stuff where you are for example
making a capture and then dragging your
opponent's pawn sideways when they have
to recapture there's a lot of typical
themes like this for example anybody
here play the Sicilian defense just a
few people okay anyone play against the
Sicilian defense yeah a bunch of people
okay so anyone who's put either side of
the Sicilian defense know there's one
very typical motif that you'll see in
just about every single variation which
is the exchange sacrifice rook takes c3
and the whole point of this is you're
dragging upon sideways to a square where
it's much worse because it is doubled it
is weak it is failing to control key
squares so there's also parts at the end
of the book about pawns moving sideways
specifically doubled pawns and how they
can fail to make a pass pawn or they or
they can fail to fight for a q square
but it's one thing to know about these
topics another one to play them well and
it's my goal that with that this book
will help the readers learn to learn to
control these pawn plays a bit better
because I found this topic it's been
largely neglected I've seen a lot of
books on pawn structures about specific
pawn structures about you know
globalizing passed pawns their pawn end
games things like this but I've never
actually seen one that talked
specifically about should you push your
pawns or not or should you double your
pawns or not and I've offered a lot of
guidelines to help people out in any
case we've been going for almost 40
minutes so what I'd like to do for the
last part of the session first I would
like to open it up to general question
answer you can ask me about me my book
anything you'd like so I'd like to do
that and then I will be selling the book
as well as signing it for anyone who
like so oh it's a funny story I didn't
really want to write a book at first but
Jacob made a bet with me and if I lost
the bet I'd have to write the book I
didn't but and it was his part of the
bed it's his business it was a one-sided
bet if he achieves his goal I have to
write the book he didn't quite get there
I mean he's certainly well based on his
progress but at some point I chose to do
it voluntarily not because I thought oh
I'm going to have to do it soon when
Jacob makes us achieve this goal but I
had some time on my hands my only
tournament planned for the fall of 2017
was the World Cup which unfortunately
did not qualify for which was I was not
happy about and just to keep myself from
jumping off a bridge or whatever I had
to keep myself busy so I thought writing
a book would be a good idea in addition
I largely wrote the book for selfish
reasons
I chose a topic that I felt I did not
understand that while myself and I
wanted to have an opportunity to look at
it in more detail and try to learn from
and my hope is if I'd certainly learn
from writing this book and my hope is if
I can learn from it you can learn from
it too it would be a nice side effect if
the results of my studies are a lot of
people are able to improve their chests
based on what I've presented after this
last tournaments I am 26 71 feet eh I
peaked at at 2686 live or like some 60
ish in the world 59 something like that
it's vit that's a very high rating I'm
very good at chess but there's a long
way to go and the better I there's one
thing that has never changed in my life
is that the better I get it just the
more I realize there is to learn if you
only are playing from one skill set
you're not going to be a very good chess
player chess is a large subset of a lot
of things it is going to be memory
understanding positional feel concrete
calculation opening preparation and game
study it's basically chess is not soccer
and soccer if you cannot catch a ball
with your hands but you're good at
kicking it with your feet that's great
you don't have to be a goalie and chess
you have to play every position that
comes in front of you and you have to
have all the tools at your disposal to
to play well so I try to not play
positionally or tactically I try to play
the way the
and demands that I play well I'm a I
don't know I'm yeah I'm good I'm on the
US Olympic team I'm you know of won gold
medals with them but there's still quite
a gap between me in the truly about the
best players in the world yes well if
you wonder what how we had such a better
result we just had better players I mean
the the teams we sent to Baku were
unquestionably by far the strongest
American teams we ever had I mean I was
like world number 59 I think at the time
which in a lot of years would be board
one for the United States of America in
this case it was board four I was you
know like maybe you've got someone who's
gonna be a very decent like well above
average board one playing board for so
it was we just had a stronger team as
for our team dynamic we got along fine
mostly we just focused on our own games
we had our coach and captain to help us
I know I didn't really I don't want to
say I didn't care cuz obviously I did
but when I was watching my teammates
play I was not bothering to think about
their games at all I was just trying to
focus on my own because I felt that the
best thing I could do for the team as
the you know playing board for is the
lowest rated player was to focus on my
own game and play as well as I can and
have faith that whatever the evaluation
of the positions next to me are my my
teammates will apply them to the best of
their ability and get there get the
points they deserve and although I must
say it's easier to have faith in your
teammates when they're like numbers two
three and six in the world so it's
easier to do with them than it is when
you know they're say one of your peers
who you know makes a lot of mistakes
just like you do right so the question
about age and how to improve is is a
very good one just because every age has
assets and liabilities you know your
brain starts slowing down a lot younger
than most people want to admit it
certainly started slowing down for me
I'm fully aware there's things I could
do when I was 18 or 20 that I can't do
now now in most fields just the the sort
of slowing down of your sheer brainpower
is you know completely overwritten by
the extra experience and knowledge
you've had from you know your years of
study or work that's why you see like
you know the best doctors are lawyers
they're not like you know 20 year old
kids they're experienced ones but
and chess which is so much about brute
force that's something that slows down
when you're older you tend to have more
experience things like this but like I
said chess is not soccer you have to do
everything I've always believed that you
have to be well-rounded to be a good
chess player if you have clear
weaknesses especially if you have a
bunch of games in the database that
people can see a well-rounded opponent
will look you up figure out where you're
not playing well and they will attack
you if you're an older player you're
struggling with memory do memory stuff
you know take memory quizzes play
blindfold chests try to remember where
your pieces are if you're struggling
with energy levels go to the gym make
sure you're fit these are problems that
older players will face more than
younger players younger players might
face problems I don't know this rook
onion because I haven't studied it yet I
just haven't had time to so in general I
think identifying the weaknesses in your
game and there is certainly a trend of
what kind of weaknesses usually show up
with age although every player is
individual and some age better than
others and in different ways so that
would be my recommendation I'm trying I
believe I'm a reasonably well-rounded
player I'm trying to study a bit of
everything which is sort of I don't know
if that's totally efficient but at the
same time if you believe you're
well-rounded you don't want to get like
much stronger at one thing win a few
games I was like okay he's good at that
let's not do that anymore I don't really
know what's between me and you know the
truly elite in the world the other guys
in the top 10 or top five if I did maybe
I would be there I don't know so I try
to study a bit of everything but also it
helps that I'm a full time professional
chess but I have the time to do so it's
easier for me to do that than for
someone who has a nine-to-five and a
bunch of kids it's people who have
actual responsibilities and and can't
just study chess all day it's much
harder for them to and so for people
like that in the real world they have to
compartmentalize their time
appropriately well for me I have much
more to devote so I can study a bit of
everything my favourite player to work
with probably the last player actually
played with yesterday I really enjoy
working with my friend Surya Ganguly
he's a very good analyst I've spent some
time in India and I really there's a
there's a very I mean in India is an
enormous place with a ton of different
people in different culture
but I definitely sort of sense an
overarching kind of culture to the way
they approach Ches improvement that I
really really like and I found that
working with Indian players has been
very helpful and Surya is the one I've
worked with the most and she's also the
one who's closest in rating to me we're
we're very close but I'd also like to
point out exactly what happens when I
play with Surya because a lot of people
when they play with their friends you
know they make quick draws and go home
I'm all the two of us we know each
other's game inside and out we work hard
look we were the last ones in the
dungeon they're playing we played 62
moves where though the whole room was
empty by the time we were done duking it
out when you're actually at the board
there's no love lost my least favorite
player to be around I'm told you
shouldn't say bad things about other
people behind their back so I'm not
gonna do that even if it's technically
not behind their back if they can see it
but I'm that one I'll rather just keep
to myself there are definitely people I
don't like I'll leave it at that all
right so if it looks like we've got like
just 10 minutes left so I'd like to just
spend the last bit at a time selling the
books to whoever would like $40 cash
preferred just because I hard time
taking credit cards and I'm happy to
sign them and yeah thanks everyone for
coming my lecture
[Applause]
[Music]